In today's video,
we're testing out
a comment asking
if it's possible to boil
water in a wooden bowl.
[Music]
All right, we've got
a couple of wooden bowls,
and we're going to try
boiling water in them.
The problem of course is
that wood does not conduct
heat nearly as well
as say a metal bowl,
which is what you'd
normally want to do this in,
or maybe glass
if it were in the microwave.
Wood pretty uncommon
for boiling.
It doesn't conduct heat well.
It's a little
bit more insulated.
So it's going to be
a little bit harder
for that heat
to transfer through.
And maybe it's so insulated even
at the outside washer
like catch on fire
or something like that
before it gets
the water boiling.
So the question is
if we can get the water to boil
without the bowl burning
up and disintegrating.
Here's the basic idea.
We are going to try and boil
water in our wooden bowl.
First on the electric burner,
then on the propane stove,
and last in our forge.
First, let's try it
on an electric burner.
[Music]
All right, we did not get water
to boil on our electric stove.
Maybe it just
doesn't get hot enough.
It burned quite a bit
on the bottom.
It didn't ever
really light on fire,
and we got water
that started heating up,
like there is steam.
and was even I think some little
bubbles down at the bottom.
It's very hot water,
but it definitely
wasn't boiling water.
So I think we need
to step our game up.
Now, we're going to try
the propane stove.
As a comparison
with this propane stove,
I want to try a metal bowl,
and we're going to time it.
We're going to see
how long it takes
for it to boil in a metal bowl,
and then compare
that to the wooden bowl after.
If it will even boil
in the metal bowl.
Is it bad that I'm hoping
this doesn't work just so
that we can light the foundry?
I am very cold.
It's a metal bowl.
It's going to go
pretty quick I suspect.
That is a decent
amount of water,
and so, it does have a certain
amount of energy it has to take
before it gets
to a boiling point,
but it's already making
little bubbles right
at the very contact,
like the bottom of the bowl.
I think it's going
to go pretty quick.
We shouldn't have
a problem here.
[Music]
Oh!
Wow!
You say that's boiling?
That's boiling.
That looks like boiling water.
2 minutes and 48 seconds,
it took for that to hit full boil.
That's pretty quick.
Yeah.
[Music]
All right.
Now we see if we can get
the water to boil,
or if we just have a bowl
that on fire, or maybe like
the top will be on fire.
Normally, when you put anything
that contains water in the fire,
the edges might burn.
But the water, it waits
until it evaporates
until the material
itself starts to burn.
So we could get a fire up here,
we could get scorching
on the bottom,
but I don't think the sides
are going to burn.
That's just not going to happen.
We'll find out.
Here we go.
It's a lot of fire.
And it is going up the sides
of the bowl quite a bit.
In fact, some
of those yellow flames
I believe are the bowl catching
on fire already.
So we've got a bowl on fire.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean
this isn't going to work.
With paper cups, I have seen it.
If you put a paper cup
and you fill water,
maybe with egg in there,
and it burns the edge,
like it burns down
to the level of the water,
because what keeps burning
is all the heat going
into the water instead of
staying on the cup itself,
but on this top rim around it,
which definitely looks
like it's lighting on fire.
Yup, that's the lacquer.
I think we're burning
the lacquer coating right now.
It does kind of smell like that.
Yeah.
This doesn't smell
like a wood burn.
This is a definitely a chemical,
like lacquer burn here.
But it's also,
down at the bottom, yeah,
we, the wood is like cracking
and stuff down at the bottom.
So down there...
Oh actually, that's true.
This is a glued bowl.
This isn't like carved
out of one piece.
So if we crack apart whatever
is holding the bowl together...
It could just...
We might want to move away.
All right.
Well, can I just point out
that this looks
like the Goblet of Fire
or something from Harry Potter,
because it's like a bowl
that's on fire.
Does anybody have
a scrap of paper?
I need to write
my name immediately.
[Music]
The flame is definitely going
out from where it was burning
the bowl, but look.
There are bubbles forming
on the side of the bowl,
and I don't know
if that's gas is expanding
through the sides of the bowl,
or if that's actually
from the heat of the water.
Know what I'm loving here is
you can actually see
this charred edge,
and then down below,
you're still seeing
that beautiful wood finish.
Not only the chart edge,
but as you said, it is a bowl
that's been glued together,
and it's splitting apart.
So we've just got these very
even sections going.
It's looking like
a flower with petals.
I wonder what would happen
if you just set one
of these bowls on fire,
would it just like boom out?
We definitely are
not at a boil yet.
No, I can still put
my hand in that so...
This is going to take longer.
[Music]
Well, it's been
31 minutes and counting.
Yeah, we are over half an hour.
Remember, it took 2 minutes
and 48 seconds to boil
in our metal bowl,
and over half an hour,
a lot of the bowl is burned.
The bottom of the bowl is
just like made of embers.
The inside of the bowl,
the lacquer is actually
starting to bubble up,
meaning the whole thing
is starting to separate.
Yeah.
If I wasn't wearing gloves, yes,
these aren't very insulating,
but there's still
some protection.
If I didn't have gloves on,
I wouldn't be putting
my hand in that,
but the fact
that I can still put my hand
in there for several seconds,
I don't think we're
that close to boiling yet.
I think we need to scale
it up one more time.
We've got our foundry.
We're going to try
a couple things.
First, we're going
to use a lot more heat,
because that thing
puts out a lot of heat,
and second, we're going to try
filling the bowl all the way,
and it might be counter
intuitive thinking like,
oh more water is going
to be harder to boil,
but it should
insulate the sides,
so less of the bowl burns up.
We're going to try it.
[Music]
This is much nicer.
I like this much more.
This is better.
Plenty of roaring
heat coming off that.
Now, I expected still going
to burn the outside of the bowl.
Oh yeah.
But the nice part about this is
that we're going to get
an ambient heat all the way
around it just from the heat
coming off of the top.
I think that's
really going to help.
There we go.
There's our lacquer.
Yes, there it goes.
And I'm sure some
of the wood lighting.
Already on the inside,
we've got that ring
of bubbles forming so...
But you can also see--
And black ring
around the top.
I think our lacquer
on the inside has
already begun to melt.
[Music]
All right, we don't have
the same kind of boil
that we did with the metal pot.
But we do have water boiling.
Weirdly, it seems to only
be boiling on one side,
where more of the heat
is directly going.
It was centered originally,
but for some reason,
it has started to settle
over to one edge,
and the other side just
isn't boiling as much.
So it's very much
where it's right
in contact with the fire.
We're getting this frothy boil,
and it's less than
half the amount of time
that we spent on the one
with the propane burner.
So yeah.
Yes, it's boiling.
We have--
We did it.
We made it happen.
So a rolling boil,
that's what happens when
the average temperature is hot
enough that it will evaporate,
and I don't think we
actually have that.
We have something
you could cook in.
I think it is boiling,
and you could cook with it,
but I don't think we have
the same type of rolling boil
where the average temperatures
hot enough to evaporate,
because it's only boiling
on the side with more heat
directly blowing on to it.
But it's less than
half the amount of time
that it took to even get
this to start bubbling,
and there was more water,
so I'm calling
that a success.
All right.
This is probably
going to fall apart.
But let's see
if we can pick it up.
Oh, it's soft.
Still bubbling.
That to me means
we really did it,
because the water
is still boiling.
Our bowl actually is basically
on fire down here,
so it's still putting
heat into the water.
So Nate was hungry,
and it's lunchtime,
and we have some boiling water.
Mmm...
Chemical water.
But while Nate makes lunch,
I'm going to try and pick
up the bowl that we had
on the propane burner.
I'm curious to see
if it's gonna hold together.
So right now,
you can see there's
ash in there,
the varnish has bubbled.
Going to pour this
out real quick.
I think mostly at this point,
it's just steaming
because it is freezing in here,
but you can see the varnish
that's just bubbled up
off of this bowl.
Now, let's look at the bottom.
Nate, look at this.
I got this one now too.
Oh, wow!
So you can already
the heat difference here.
That's pretty cool
looking bowl honestly.
It's also much lighter weight.
Right?
It lost a lot of mass.
We set out to see
if you can boil water
in a wooden bowl, and yes,
it turns out you can,
it's just horrendously impractical.
In a survival situation,
if you didn't have a metal bowl,
you would probably have
to stick a wooden bowl
right in the center of a fire.
So...
And I don't think you'd be able
to do it too many times
before your bowl got used up.
There are traditional methods
of boiling water inflammable
containers by like taking
a hot rock out of the fire,
and putting that into the water
inside the container,
but we were trying
to actually just boil it the way
you boil stuff in a bowl or pot.
Guys, that's it for today.
But you know,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Give that a click as well.
If you hit this bomb
in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to our channel.
That way, you'll never miss
out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.